so presumably now the focus is back on
number five you've got before
yes back again hang on to them so back
to get number five but you don't know
who you're gonna fight yet
no because because the fifth belt is I
know yeah well that's being decided in
February
Wow it's gonna be deciding a new year
but I'm gonna be in training anyway so
I'm still like up in the air and what to
do and so on okay so it's going to be
either Tyson Fury or dijanna Wilder Wow
so between the two of them if you were a
betting man who do you think you'll be
fighting I don't know some you're my
manager I go by the color of gloves this
is why I know my manager you want my
expertise
Stephen Graham Eufaula box saying yeah
what do you think I think any any one of
them yeah anyone do you care have you
you can't call that fright again so blow
any one of the meals well the last time
it was a draw so yeah but so you don't
you don't care or do you have a
preference the preference would be the
champion who is Deontay Wilder because
it's a championship fight but Tyson
Fury's so talented as well and it's the
best of British so why not I would fight
anyone so even one of them is but not
you don't about
time is the time what is it there fights
in February you know how quickly do you
think it'll happen where you're going
for that filth felt will it be in 2020 v
belt that will be the dream that would
be the dream so there February I'll
probably going the March when let's say
providing a win and I put my prayers in
and the champion wins and why not I know
well I hope you do because then you
could be a guest on the show again
[Applause]
you
you